[Música]
vamos ahora así con nuestros titulares
de la prensa para ello yo me acompaña en
el estudio rosa pérez masdéu rosa
bienvenida feliz miércoles para ti esta
semana como ya levantamos el noticiero
facebook no deja de ser noticia vamos
entonces a repasar qué dicen los
periódicos sobre todo primero en nuestra
región sobre estas revelaciones de la
desempleada y la compañía vamos a
empezar con el países de américa soccer
ver no es verdad el que antepongamos los
beneficios al bienestar de los usuarios
esto dice soccer varias y titula el país
de américa buenos dias raúl así es y ya
vemos que los medios internacionales ya
después de que el lunes la noticia fuera
la caída de la plataforma pues ya se
centran en las revelaciones y en la
testificación ayer ante el congreso de
esta ex empleada y aquí vemos pues si
los tres medios a los que vamos a hacer
referencia empezamos por el país que nos
da un dato muy relevante raúl y un poco
la explicación por la que todo el mundo
tiene los ojos puestos en facebook
todavía y es que el 60 por ciento de la
población mundial con acceso a internet
es clienta usuaria de las plataformas de
mark zuckerberg entonces este es un
poder pues que puede tener ciertos
parecidos con poderes de los medios de
comunicación pero también tiene una
parte inédita no y el país destaca
precisamente pues esto que es de querer
ver niega la mayor parte de las
revelaciones de francis haugen que hizo
ayer ante el congreso y dice que pues la
mayoría carecen de lógica pero también
este medio destaca el hecho de que mark
zuckerberg ha necesitado un mes de
revelaciones periodísticas y una
testificación ante el congreso pues para
reaccionar vamos ahora con el universal
en méxico rosa dice soccer ver se
defiende y se niega que facebook
anteponga los beneficios de la seguridad
más o menos también como lo tituló el
país eso es pues todos los medios se
centran un poco en esto no puede
respuesta en la respuesta a la
informante diciendo algo y mark
zuckerberg negando lo no y dicen pues
que esto francisca hogar y nació un
relato que consideran despiadado pues
alegando que facebook o oculta
información tanto a los gobiernos como a
los usuarios y al público y pues que
mark zuckerberg
destaca que no reconoce la imagen que se
está pintando de la compañía y esto es
lo que quiso dirigir ayer a sus
empleados en esta carta que finalmente
optó por hacer pública en su perfil de
su propia red social vamos ahora con el
world with you now' también en américa
pero en eeuu el testimonio del
informante de facebook crea el momento
para una regulación más estricta de la
tecnología eso es raúl el wall street
journal recordemos que es el medio que
está a la raíz de toda la polémica que
se está generando hoy en día porque fue
el wall street journal precisamente
quien inició la investigación
llamada de los facebook papers quien 2
quien reveló estos documentos filtrados
por francis joven la informante que
estaba testificando ayer ante el
congreso ante el senado de eeuu y
precisamente pues vemos que es una
investigación periodística que cumple
con su cometido porque los ojos de todo
el mundo están puestos en esto mark
zuckerberg ha reaccionado y precisamente
pues está ahora otra vez en el ojo de
mira
el hecho de que la opinión pública es
que hay que regular estos gigantes
tecnológicos el problema es que nadie
sabe muy bien cómo hacerlo porque mark
zuckerber por un lado una de las
recordemos una de las informaciones que
más se compensó a hacer de estos
facebook papers fue el hecho de como
instagram precisamente afectaba la salud
mental de las adolescentes este fue de
los primeros temas que empezaron a tener
repercusión a nivel mundial mark
zuckerberg se defiende diciendo que las
adolescentes pues se enfrentan un poco a
los mismos problemas de siempre y aquí
pues raúl ahí esta línea tan fina entre
lo que comentábamos no decir que algo no
tiene precedentes o decir que no hay
nuevo nada nuevo bajo el sol digamos
ciertamente los adolescentes pues tienen
unas problemáticas particulares pero
facebook o instagram pues añade también
unas nuevas condiciones bien distintas y
aquí precisamente el wall street journal
dice pues que hay este precisamente este
problema de cómo regular facebook sin al
mismo tiempo coartar el debate público
la libertad de expresión dice facebook
tendría que abogar en primer lugar para
empoderar a los padres y darles más
poder a las cuentas de los menores rosa
vamos a cambiar ahora de continente como
lo registra como lo registran en europa
vamos ahora con le monde en francia mark
zuckerber asegura que no prioriza los
beneficios económicos en detrimento de
la seguridad así lo titula demonio eso
es en mira porque una de uno de los
temas también que está sobre la mesa
sobre cómo regular facebook pues como
comentábamos precisamente ayer una
cuestión sería tratarlo como un medio de
comunicación y por lo tanto penalizarlo
por las informaciones falsas que se
publiquen sobre la plataforma pero pues
esto pone también ciertos
obstáculos no ciertas complicaciones
porque pues son usuarios no no son
medios de comunicación con un editor con
una supervisión entonces por otro lado
otra de las opciones es también pues que
haya más transparencia en cómo funcionan
los algoritmos pero precisamente una de
las críticas de francis joven es que
pues es un sistema muy vertical el de
facebook y que mark zuckerberg está un
poco al cargo
de vivir y de saber cómo funciona todo
esto por otro lado mark zuckerberg según
lemond se defiende diciendo que
precisamente en base a esto pues la
informante no tiene conocimiento de
todos los aspectos de los que habla como
por ejemplo del tema de los menores pero
sã pasemos a the garden lo tiene al lado
eso es pues es que the gardian señala
otro punto no y es que precisamente
hablamos de las plataformas y de su
poder digital pero como toda industria
pues tiene pues aspectos digamos muy
materiales no y precisamente francisco
ven una de las cosas que denuncia y que
destaca este periódico británico es como
ya estaban sobrepasados los empleados
que se dedicaban pues a la moderación de
contenido
precisamente la informante estaba al
cargo de las inferencias en el tema de
las elecciones y como ella dice que
puedes mejorar o afinar mart más con el
algoritmo que digamos filtra los
contenidos hubiera supone supuesto una
carga de trabajo imposible de gestionar
rosso y con toda esta información de
facebook vamos ahora a analizarlo con
nuestro primer invitado del día
muchísimas gracias nos vemos mañana con
más titulares de la prensa